[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
a half thousand miles away from Britain
Jamaica has remnants of its Colonial
past present everywhere
but it's the country's future is
changing
Sky News can reveal the coronation of
King Charles has sped up the
government's plans for a Jamaican
Republic
senior Minister told me legislation for
a public vote could come as soon as this
month
we're looking at holding the referendum
in
2024 okay so as early as 2024 we're
saying that Jamaica could potentially be
a republic time has gone
Jamaican in Jamaican hands
in downtown Kingston not all Jamaicans
are ready to cut ties with Britain so
soon
yes what I don't see is not gonna be
better
we don't think we are ready for it we
don't have the resource
um we don't it's like a child
cannot leave a child like that and I
want to tell you something stick to the
evil that you know
I'm not saying that good you know
I'm not going to tell you that they're
good they are evil but I will stick to
them to the evil that I know
but does the status quo help Jamaicans
pay the bills many young people
especially in asking what's the
relevance how does you know a king
affect the price of bread
[Music]
a recent Royal trip to Jamaica where
senior Royals failed to apologize for
slavery has also hit a nerve
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened why
not a full apology is it because you may
have to give back the wealth of the
monarchy taken from the people taken
from the places that were colonized
taken from the places where the people
were enslaved
but it's not just the royal family
swaying public opinion in Jamaica
winrush
personal for people the policies that
are racist and unjust
by virtue of nationality and and ethnic
background and the color of your skin
it's just
it's just in part what you're calling
racist policies of the British
government are influencing Jamaica's
decision to become a republic yes
strong sentiments but by no means a done
deal
polling just about favors a Jamaican
Republic
the winning hand could be played in
2024.
summer Chowdhury Sky News in Kingston
Jamaica